This is Ajax, and
I've trained him to help me find kea nests
He's the only kea dog in the country
and I guess that means the world
People are really shocked when you tell them
that there are less kea then there are kiwis
I've been training Ajax since he was a pup
he walks around the forest all day with me
he hops in helicopters,
he comes on boats
he's been caving
Yeah he comes everywhere with me
He's got a good keen nose, and
he's able to let me know if there's a kea close by or
if there's one still in the hole
he'll indicate by standing there quite awkwardly
with his nose directly in the hole
It's really sad when you come across a kea nest
that you've been monitoring
and watching the chicks grow
and all of a sudden you get there and they’re gone
and you know they haven't fledged
because it's too early
and you know they've been predated by some pest
Yeah it gets you down, because
you think about that happening
in hundreds of kea nests every year
all across the South Island
It does make you think
can we win this battle?
Good boy, good boy!
That's a perfect indication, that's the best you've done!
I want people to look at keas
as an important species that we have here
in the South Island of New Zealand
And I want stories like this
about me and Ajax
to make people aware
of how neat and special they are
Working to conserve an endangered species
is really rewarding
every day's an adventure
And it's helping the world
in my little corner of the globe